welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness dropped a new
featurette with unseen footage and proof
that sam raimi will interrupt his shift
as a poll bearer to sell this movie we
wanted the fans to go oh how cool how
did he know that's how i react to these
things oh how cool oh how cool oh how
cool i'm gonna break down all the
amazing new shots to help contextualize
exactly what could be happening in this
movie let's go first new shot shows a
close-up of the eye of agamotto as it
twists open now whereas before strange
and the other sorcerers used this
necklace to store the time stone ever
since the time stone was atomized and
that necklace was broken by thanos and
infinidor when he called it a fake it
was never seen again after strange's
neck in end game until it reappeared in
spider-man no way home now this necklace
could be the real eye of agamotto with
the one that thanos broke being a false
illusion when strange hid the time stone
in a pocket dimension on titan or if
they are going by the comics this could
actually be the second of three total
eyes of agamotto we saw this new one
twist open briefly in spider-man no way
home when he's trying to get the box
back from peter on that train in the
mirror dimension and now this close-up
gives a peek at its contents a series of
glowing particles that seem to revolve
upon concentric orbital paths like
planetary bodies in a solar system or
electrons in an atom i just love that
this necklace could contain a whole
pocket universe like the cat orion's
collar and men in black but in another
shot later sinister strange gets hit
with a spell that unleashes a swarm of
golden glowing runes that look a lot
like the rudes that swarmed strange when
he entered obang's library of cagliostro
in what if episode 4. i wonder if these
runes are what's inside of the eye of
agamotto each one representing a
different stored spell spells that get
unleashed and strange's duel with
sinister strange now again there's that
shot of the vessel hatch door opening
into what i think are the ruins of the
utopia parallel where finally i pointed
out in a recent video you can see
strange's wrist watch strapped to that
crank knob the term crank knob also
referring to what i am on twitter just a
reminder that this watch was given as
strange by christine palmer in the 2016
film and was broken as strange sought
out camara taj by a few muggers and then
this watch went on to serve as a symbol
of strange's unhealable wound of his
broken hands but also his mastery of the
mental and mystical over the physical
here the watch may have been used by
strange or variant christine palmer
since she's beside him in this moment as
a kind of key to the secret backdoor
where inside of this place they hid the
book that they are now trying to
retrieve based on its blue glow as
opposed to the different colors that the
dark hole glows and the different
texture of this book on the poster that
we saw i think this may be the book of
vishanti sought out to counteract the
darkhold spells now unusual detail here
when we cut the outside of the hatch
that watch is now missing so we may be
seeing two different times this portal
is accessed or maybe the watch is
quickly removed after the hatch opens or
maybe it is a one-time key that
dissipates after it is used then more
shots of strange in the surreal version
of the sanctum cast on the stormy beach
like a shipwreck a close-up of his feet
stepping up out of the sea water onto
the staircase actually later a bts shot
shows the camera pushing in on stranger
behind in the scene showing new statues
that have been added on either side of
the banisters some thin figure holding a
torch actually later in sinister's
strangest sanctum there is a chandelier
of a similar statue holding up those
lights making me wonder if this
nightmarish sanctum ground floor is
actually part of sinister strange's
abode the shot of strange and wanda in
the white blossoming orchard shows a
petal floating upward past wanda which i
get it might just be a petal caught in
the breeze but still gives off a
surrealist quality especially when we
know this setting is an illusion being
cast by wanda to hide her darker
hellscape then some new shots of the
ribbon monster we have guests citrac
whatever this thing is plowing through
the utopian parallel chasing america
chavez and defender strange as they run
along a twisted road that leads to the
one largest structure chunk that is
still mostly intact but the scale of
this setting is just so insane to
comprehend deep in the background behind
them is a massive column that looks like
it should be in the foreground judging
from its size and overall frame how
large is this column and what kind of
building was it part of now folks what
if you clicked on this video and i only
gave you like uh a fraction of the total
easter eggs that i was able to find you
would feel pretty cheated wouldn't you
well whenever you streaming services
like netflix without expressvpn it's
like tuning into anything and only
getting a fraction of what's available
to you well thanks to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video expressvpn lets
you change your online location so that
you can access geographically blocked
content because depending on what
country you live in you may only get
access to like some of the content
that's out there that's not how it
should work so open yourself up to whole
new libraries of shows and films without
having to pay for a new streaming
service just this week i use expressvpn
to watch south park on uk netflix i just
switched my location to the uk refresh
the page and boom i like how easy
expressvpn is to use there's no
confusion no wasted time and the whole
thing runs fast you just fire up the app
and download with just one click it's a
top rated vpn provider rated number one
by techradar find out how you can get
three months of expressvpn for free by
visiting expressvpn.com
new rockstars or by clicking the link in
the description below then there's a
shout out defender wong meeting with
some blue cloaked i'm guessing
commentary elders a later shot shows him
with strange america master hamir inside
kamar taj and sam remy twists the camera
around them similar to the shot we've
seen him use for wanda seance in one of
the promos i just love how rainy moves
the camera in general another shot shows
defender wong on a snowy mountain cliff
side much like our man samwise gamgy
presumably this is part of defender
strange's battle on top of that mountain
then there's this new close-up of
strange in the illuminati holding cell
with an interesting tile or stained
glass configuration behind him to the
left made up of this one recurring
interlocking shape if you look closely
it's got like three triangular points
from the bottom like a star and then the
top part of it three longer pieces that
extend out further from the other side i
don't know if there's any significance
to this but i'm wondering if it could be
the sigil of this illuminati or whatever
this multiversal panel is called we
again see the ultron centuries escorting
strange to that courtroom but now we see
a shot where the tall doors open just a
neat parallel of the shot of the doors
opening on peter parker as he walked
into the sanctum and no way home then
there's a bts shot of strange america's
fight with gargantos on the street
there's a sign for a rostock company
clam house i don't know if there's
anything to this but i just find it
amusing that there is a huge clam house
right next to where they fight a
tentacled creature known as a namor
villain another behind the scenes shot
at camera taj in the foreground shows
the sorceress that i'm pretty sure is
sarah the mystery funko pop figurine
he's probably gonna be on the level of
rintra as a sorcerer who has a larger
role than the rest then there's a shot
of mordo hitting strange's cuffs with
the sword in the illuminati courtroom
but now you can see some green sparks
flying off of it meaning he must have
broken that green power source on the
cuffs new shots of wanda fighting the
captain marvel variant looking awesome
you can see more clearly how covered in
that blood she is looking a lot like
carrie when she turns on her enemies you
can also see how that red chaos magic
just churns in her palms as the yellow
blast is repelled then inside commentage
a door suddenly shuts as strange wong
american hamir react to it just some
more great camera work by ramy reminding
us a lot of his evil dead gliding camera
shots now the final news shot shows
wanda trapped in a sharp edged broken
prism as a red blast hits her you can
see her reflections behind her repelling
those attacks on the shards in the upper
right now i think someone is trying to
encase her in the mirror dimension as
wanda tries to break out of it causing
the glass of that dimension to shatter
around her the other red blasts could be
coming from her variant wanda as we know
there are going to be two of them or
maybe even one of the spells cast from
her own hands rebounding around her now
a reminder to support new rock stars by
checking out our great merch options and
new rockstarsmerch.com like this moon
knight inspired tomb of the moon god
design follow me on instagram and
twitter at ea boss following your
rockstar subscribe to interex for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you